one of the great and slightly strange
dangers of falling in love with someone
is how we may respond the day they start
to love us back some of the reason we
fall in love with people is because we
long to escape from ourselves into the
embrace of a person who appears as
beautiful perfect and accomplished as we
feel ourselves to be floored down than
mediocre but what if such a being were
one day to turn around and love us back
nothing could discredit them faster how
could they be as divine as we'd hope for
when they have the bad taste to approve
of someone like us it turns out that one
of the central requirements of a good
relationship is a degree of affection
for ourselves built up over the years
largely in childhood we need a legacy of
being deserving of love in order not to
respond very obtusely
to the affections granted to us by adult
partners without a decent amount of
self-love the love of another person
will always prove sickening and
misguided and we will self-destructively
though unconsciously set out to repel or
disappoint it it will simply feel more
normal and therefore comfortable to be
disliked or ignored when that is mostly
what we have known if we're not wholly
convinced of our own love ability
receiving affection can appear like
being bestowed a prize for an
accomplishment we don't feel we ever
earned people unfortunate enough to fall
in love with self-hating types must
brace themselves for the recriminations
due to false flatterers there is an old
joke made by Groucho Marx about not
deigning to belong to a club that would
accept someone like him as a member we
laugh at the Marxist position because of
it's absurd contradictions how is it
possible that we should both wish to
join a club and yet lose that wish as
soon as it comes true why wouldn't we
just be happy to have been allowed into
this club the answer lies in self-hatred
because for many of us be
accepted into a grand and beautiful club
doesn't feel like what our inner psyches
have been shaped to accept we wonder how
we can continue to believe in a club or
indeed a beloved now that they believe
in us
there is usually a troubling Marxist
moment in every relationship a moment
when it becomes clear that love is going
to be reciprocated that we won't simply
admire someone from afar without hope of
mutuality the way the crisis is resolved
depends on the balance between self love
and self hatred in our own characters if
self hatred gains the upper hand then
the one who is being loved back will
declare that the beloved on some excuse
or other is just not good enough for
them not good enough by virtue of
associating with no goods but if self
love gains the upper hand then both
partners may accept that seeing their
love reciprocated is not proof of how
low the beloved is but instead of how
lovable they have themselves turned out
to be it emerges that knowing how to
love ourselves a little can be one of
the kindest and therefore most romantic
things we can ever learn to do for our
partners
you